t'en fais pas et est entre les mains
d'un conteur hors pair
l'amérique n'a produit que trois grands
auteurs classiques
mark twain jerome david salinger et moi
je suis johnattan fine je n'écris que
des chefs-d'oeuvre et bientôt très
bientôt je serai connu ce n'est pas son
histoire
enfin si mais c'est pas lui qui va
vouloir raconter c'est moi toute ma vie
et mon père a brillé par son absence
j'ai envie de devenir écrivain
ah oui papa il ya un guide à cette
lettre tu sais d'où il a rédigé de
prison ma mère est morte et j'ai pas vu
mon père depuis 18 ans ils peuvent se
les chèques falsifiés
je suis pas fier d'avoir très envie de
toi
à cet instant précis de l'histoire
je suis un citoyen de ces états unis là
tu différend avec ces temps reculés de
propriété ce que j'ai toujours été un
artiste quelque part au fond de moi je
savais qu'il réapparaître un jour qu'est
ce qui t'a donné envie de travailler
pour les sans abri on a vécu pas trop
tard le prochain arrêt c'est la mort né
si je restais au même endroit pendant si
longtemps il me retrouverais
je voudrais le chambre pour cette nuit
un plaisir de voir nicolas malgré les
circonstances je fais exactement ce que
tu fais toi je recueille du matériel
c'est juste ma vie la vie se recueillir
c'est que les écrivains et
particulièrement les poètes ont une
prédisposition pour la faune
tu es moi chez moi qui te supporter une
croix je sais pas toi
je suis mon père je crois qu'il ya
besoin d'une aide extérieure
quatre autres écrit la fera beau être le
plus talentueux des écrivains occupe
avec des mains c'est à possiblement fait
entrer personne ne lira jamais on nous a
placés sur cette terre pour aider notre
prochain icône à elvis formidable c'est
un shader